Everyone has had something to say about fat
Thor in Avengers: Endgame, and now Robert
Downey Jr. has added his two cents.
Chatting with Variety as part of the outlet's
cover story all about Thor himself, Chris
Hemsworth, Downey Jr. spoke out about the
God of Thunder's striking new physique.
"Thor!"
"Is he asleep?"
The five years after the Avengers' post-Infinity
War face-off with Thanos, which ended with
Thor decapitating the tyrant, weren't kind
to the God of Thunder.
The mighty Asgardian sank into a pit of grief
isolating himself to a small shack in New
Asgard and spending his days eating, drinking,
and yelling at kids while playing Fortnite.
He emerged after the time jump sporting a
shaggy beard, unkempt hair that grew to his
shoulders, and a protruding belly courtesy
of barrels of beer and newfound love for Cheez
Whiz.
Chubby Thor divided fans, but where does the
Iron Man actor sit on the spectrum?
Downey Jr. revealed to Variety that he adores
what Hemsworth did with the character, and
praised his all-or-nothing performance.
"Boy, did he go bonkers.
He went out to the bleeding edge.
I have a rule, which is if you think you're
at 70 percent, then start pulling back, because
it's probably at 105 [percent].
He went out into some pretty risky atmosphere
of nuttiness."
"I think I'm having a panic attack."
"Get it together!"
Hemsworth relished the experience of pushing
himself to his limits and continuing to take
risks with Thor.
In fact, Hemsworth was so excited about being
able to play Thor in a different way and enjoyed
chubbier Thor so much that he pushed to keep
the hero's plumper shape throughout the entirety
of Endgame, lobbying to not have Thor undergo
the planned mid-movie transformation where
he gets fit again.
He told Variety,
"I like that anything goes.
You're not locked into expectations.
I enjoyed that version of Thor.
It
was so different than any other way I played
the character.
And then it took on a life of its own."
"Give me that.
You have the little one."
Hemsworth even found some joy in the not-so-fun
parts of portraying fat Thor, namely the heavy
silicone prosthetics and extra weights he
had to wear, saying,
"Physically, it was a good three hours in
hair and makeup.
Then the prosthetic suit, particularly for
the shirt-off scene, that was a big silicone
that weighed about 90 pounds.
It was certainly exhausting.
I had weights on my hands and ankles just
to have my arms and legs swing differently
when I shuffled along through the set.
People just kept coming up and cuddling me
like a big bear or rubbing my belly like I
was pregnant.
Or trying to sit on my lap like I was Santa
Claus.
You get a lot of affection.
I felt like an old man, an old grandpa, with
a bunch of kids around."
Downey Jr. wasn't the only Endgame guy who
had kind words to say about chubby Thor.
The film's co-director, Anthony Russo, shared
with Variety that Thor's arc in Endgame was
among his favorite narratives in the entire
film.
Like Downey Jr., Russo also applauded Hemsworth's
commitment to his character.
"Part of Chris' magic as a comedic actor is
his dedication to the depth of the character
on a very earnest level...It's so devious
and subversive when comedy is coming from
a place of complete commitment and emotional
complexity."
While those over in the Marvel camp clearly
couldn't get enough of fat Thor, others were
less keen on the character's new look.
His transformation from fit to fat, largely
due to the trauma of the Decimation and the
subsequent grief Thor struggled to work through,
didn't sit well with some viewers, many of
whom felt that Avengers: Endgame was poking
fun at his troubles rather than celebrating
him in the way they felt the film was doing
with other heroes.
At the end of the day, though, it looks like
fat Thor is here to stay, as Hemsworth has
no desire to exit the Marvel Cinematic Universe
any time soon.
"I'd still love to do more, to be honest.
And I don't know what the plan is.
I feel like we've opened up such a different
character.
I feel more energized for the possibility
of where it could go."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about the MCU
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.